this video is sponsored by incogni
U.S suburbs are symbols of the American
dream in the post-war boom period owning
that house with the two cars was
considered the Apex of prosperity and
modern living clean streets manicured
Lawns brand new highway infrastructure
the family living comfortably on that
salary mom staying home to take care of
the 2.5 children following the horrors
of World War II such living standards
were almost utopian for the average
person and yet America had made it
possible welcome to the new golden age
of post-war civilization but something
was wrong as the suburbs flourished
other parts of U.S towns and cities were
rotting away creating huge sorts of dead
tissue in the heart of the country when
you drove out of those beautiful suburbs
you often found yourself in areas best
described as post-apocalyptic centers of
culture and commerce were left condemned
and abandoned vibrant communities
disappeared formerly bustling main
streets were deserted meanwhile the
suburbs continued to grow unabated and
in many areas continue to do so to this
day since then however the post-war
economic boom was supplanted by painful
stagnation and mountains of death owning
a house let alone living off a single
salary is but a ludicrous fantasy for
the Young Generation depression and
loneliness run rampant within Society
affecting many especially commutes are
getting longer traffic jams are getting
worse the infrastructure is slowly
falling apart the American dream is dead
and it was the suburbs that delivered
the killing blow how is that possible
what on Earth happened here let's find
out I've identified three key points
which I'm going to cover and I would
also like to thank incogni for
sponsoring today's video incognit helps
protect your privacy by reaching out the
holders of your personal data on your
behalf and requesting their removal
these personal data ranges from your
full legal name phone number date of
birth home address or even shopping
habits the process of removal is fully
automated once launched it does not
require any further action from you
Incognito will be dealing with holders
of your personal data on your behalf
imagine giving out your contact
information somewhere and it get sold
off and you start receiving unwanted
marketing or even scam calls or if some
website with your personal data on it
gets breached and then someone takes out
a loan under your name and identity not
a fun time this is where incognit comes
in or hopefully before all of this by
handling personal data removal for you
on your behalf first create an account
and tell them whose data they'll be
requesting to remove second Grant
incoming permission to act on your
behalf they'll be contacting holders of
your personal information to get it
wiped from their databases third kick
back and relax and watching company
handle all that for you you'll be able
to keep track of their progress live
don't let your personal data fall into
the wrong hands the first 100 people to
use my code at the link below will get
60 of incognay thank you for checking
out incognay and it's like this help
support what I do and now back to the
video when we compare the European
suburb to the American counterparts what
differences are there the European
suburb is usually denser has mixed
zoning mid Rises there are local
workplaces a public transit connection
and busy highways are LED outside the
residential areas in the us suburbs are
much more spread out there is no mix
zoning or mid Rises meaning there are
only single family homes workplaces are
far away usually there is no public
transit and highways are put right
through the neighborhood and so U.S
suburbs and them being spread out we
call this urban sprawl which leads to
our first point
[Music]
right outside of town there is a hill
with a large tree on top overlooking a
Creek Band a place where children would
Adventure where young couples would have
their first kiss well now it's all built
up with same-looking suburbs but small
Forest locals used to hike and relax in
all bulldozed for a suburb that race
track people would hang out on a
Saturday evening closed demolished and
replaced by a suburb Billy Bob's Ranch
where he would teach kids to ride horses
in his free time gone destroyed for a
suburb that cornfield kids used to play
in during summer break eaten by a suburb
the church that served as a community
center for a century it had to go to
make way for the new highway Uncle
Mike's General Store where he would sell
his wife's cannolis on Sunday went
bankrupt and closed as soon as the
Walmart Supercenter opened everything
that made the American Town what it was
is gone destroyed to make way for an
Endless Sea of same-looking houses was
it worth it for developers it sure as
hell was they made out like Bandits as
for you the taxpayer I have bad news
you've inherited a Ponzi scheme a
ticking Financial Time Bomb those
beautiful new suburbs since they are so
spread out they need lots of
infrastructure makes sense right
everything is for the report so you need
more of everything water mains sewage
pipes underground cables and a lot of
Road surface a lot of Road surface the
good news is the federal government and
the Department of Transportation paid
for most of those the city barely needed
to put in any money the bad news is all
this infrastructure has a planned
lifespan 15 20 25 years after which you
need to overhaul them this means tearing
up the road digging up everything
replacing the piping and the wires and
having to re-asphalt potentially
hundreds of kilometers of roads this is
of course extremely expensive so who's
paying for it the suburbs right from
their property taxes and no by being so
spread out thus housing fewer people
they do not generate enough money to pay
for their own infrastructure the suburbs
are essentially welfare Queens therefore
planned overhauls have to be paid with
more new development U.S cities have to
grow constantly to get additional tax
revenue to finance the existing
infrastructure and if a city stops
growing everything falls apart almost
instantly when such a city is threatened
with bankruptcy due to its suburbs the
federal government steps in to bail them
out and finance the overhauls with your
taxpayers money so not only are U.S
suburbs gobbling up the historic
landscape they fleece taxpayers for
billions of dollars each year but hey
the real estate developers got rich and
the Suburban inhabitants are very happy
with their quality of life and that
there are no minorities in their
neighborhood
[Music]
the post World War II Suburban Doom was
in large part due to low interest loans
for veterans offered by the government
white veterans that is in addition there
was this thing called redlining where
the government delineated urban areas
where minorities lived usually
African-Americans and declared the area
hazardous and unsuitable for investment
this meant that inhabitants of the area
would not be able to get mortgages or
loans because Banks wouldn't issue them
any because the areas they lived in were
unsuitable for investment quote-unquote
this government meddling crippled
business activity plus cementing
millions of people in poverty it also
kept black people out of the suburbs
since they couldn't afford to move there
which was of course the whole point but
here's the funny part by nature of being
densely populated Urban areas many inner
city black majority neighborhoods still
produced quite a lot of tax revenue more
than the surrounding white suburbs
actually which were as we discussed
financially unviable so cities took the
revenue from Redline impoverished ethnic
majority areas and spent it on
subsidizing white Suburbia talk about
Injustice meanwhile in the clean and
beautiful subsidized suburbs a silent
epidemic was spreading turns out living
in a box in a sea of other same looking
boxes in the middle of a street
Labyrinth is bad for your mental health
especially if you had to stay there all
day long like those stay at home wives
this was the true traditional
conservative lifestyle where women were
socially pressured to not pursue any
careers to stay home barefoot and
pregnant to be soft quiet amicable and
do not wear pants yes if you wore
fantasy woman many people would
ostracize you all the way till the 70s
depending on how conservative the area
was being forced into roles weasel
behavior and even clothing naturally did
not do a lot of good for Suburban women
substance abuse was consequently
widespread you're stuck in a box all day
long doing housework and tending to kids
then there is your husband who does not
necessarily treat you like is equal a
traditional conservatism and all you
have no meaningful career pads you
always have to act a certain way only
wear cutesy dresses and put up with your
husband's constantly if you
think I'm exaggerating check out these
AdWords from the era keep her where she
belongs show her it's a man's world buy
our coffee or your husband will beat you
and my favorite it's nice to have a girl
around the house it doesn't get any more
overt than that I think in the
traditional conservative Suburban Utopia
women were treated as second-class
Citizens basically as a result when you
see those smiling housewives on 1950s
illustrations well they were most likely
on something alcohol pills whatever
substance they could get their hands on
to Bear the boredom and being treated as
sentient property but hey at least
sometimes you could get away from it all
by taking the kids somewhere not on foot
not on bike not only bus train or train
either as those who are long
discontinued your only option was none
other than
foreign by virtue of being so spread out
suburbs are core Centric there is no
other way of getting around distances
are too large on foot and biking is too
dangerous due to heavy traffic public
transportation cannot be built either
since houses are far apart much fewer
people will live within practical
distance of any Transit stop if you put
a tram stop in a European suburb you got
hundreds of people living near it in the
American suburbs it's a few dozen
meaning our Transit line could not have
a ridership justifying its existence and
it was around this time that Americans
discovered the phenomenon called induced
demand meaning the more roads and
parking capacity you build the more
people will choose to thrive and the
worse will traffic get basically people
will choose cars until it's no longer
viable meaning only when the road gets
completely clogged do they start looking
for Alternatives like public transit or
biking in the suburbs there are no
Alternatives cars are your only option
and you need them constantly a big part
of this is the lack of mixed zoning you
can't have say a corner store in your
street because only residential
buildings are allowed commercial
buildings are usually heavily
concentrated in one area which were
before way for most people you can't
just walk down to Mike's General Store
for some beer you have to get in your
car and drive 15 minutes to the Walmart
Supercenter to accommodate all the
people forced to drive massive car
infrastructure had to be built in the
U.S highways and strobes were put right
through the suburbs and not only there
see while more and more people lived in
the suburbs their jobs were still in the
city and now you had hundreds of
thousands of people wanting to commute
there by car The Logical answer was to
build out proper public transportation
with some large Suburban parking garages
so people can leave their cars there and
go to the city via public transit this
was The Logical solution so initially
Americans started demolishing their
cities to make way for giant Urban
freeways particularly areas with
minorities in them if you can believe
that if you look at before and after
photos of American cities the difference
really is shocking some of these aren't
even cities anymore just a few loose
buildings among the highways and parking
lots when I saw this photo at first I
thought it was some bombed out city
after a war but no this is just what
cars and suburbanization did to downtown
Houston suburbanization has done
irreparable damage to the us gobbling up
the landscape locking taxpayers into
Ponzi schemes being tools for
discrimination and gilded cages for
women forcing enormous highways to be
built City centers to be demolished all
in the name of corporate business
interest as the American landscape
disappeared as downtowns were torn down
as American cultures Roots were
systematically broiled and upturned real
estate developers car manufacturers and
big retail chains made billions upon
billions in profits from taxpayers money
essentially you know memes like you know
nothing can be happy and getting the
party eat the bug those aren't some
distant future dystopia that's life in
the suburbs the bank owns your house via
mortgage your car by a loan and you live
in a cardboard holding pan in a sea of
other holding pens which would be your
pod as for eating the bug 24 million
Americans live in so-called food deserts
areas with little to no access to fresh
food and the biggest Factor there is
transportation in Europe you can just
hop onto affordable public transit to
get to a store selling fresh food in the
US if you can't afford the annual cost
of car ownership that's 10 700 28
dollars an average you might lose access
to fresh food you'll have to eat the bug
at the end of the day Americans must
decide what the U.S should be a soulless
corporate machine that eats human lives
and churns have money or an actual
country with Community culture and
cohesive Society by the people for the
people should you as an American want
the second option there are a number of
tried and tested things you can do
bother your local decision makers to
Institute mix zoning support local
measures to densify the suburbs so
they'll be able to pay for themselves
support Highway removals and oppose Road
widening advocate for public transit and
separated bike paths at your local town
hall meeting look if any such measures
will be on the ballot sometime then go
and vote for them in your local
elections read up on what each candidate
wants to do about the issues mentioned
here pick the one with the best plans
and put the X next to their name oh and
you can also join the strong towns
movement at strongtowns.org an
organization working to fix U.S Suburbia
and if you want to learn more about the
topic of urbanism and transportation in
the description I put a list of books
you can check out for further reading
thank you for watching and thanks to
incogni for sponsoring today's video as
I've mentioned you can use the link in
the description and get 60 and off and
I'll be seeing you next time